Amanda Amanda Amanda asks how do you
define simple living man I mean I can
define simple if I was a fine living so
sometimes people ask what is minimalism
the thing I say about minimalism is
minimalism is the thing that gets us
past the things so we can make room for
life's most important things now
sometimes that word minimalism is the
perfect word because it conjures up
these images of like stark white walls
and empty warehouses and owning very
little and sometimes that's intriguing
for folks because the average American
house has 300,000 items in it so we're
we're steeped in stuff and minimalism
feels like the the antidote to that and
I I personally believe that minimalism
is a tool so it's part of the antidote
it's a tool for us to to rid our lives
of the excess so we can live more simply
so if minimalism isn't the right word
for you maybe there are other words for
you sometimes people will just say
simple living or simplicity or
simplifying or deliberate living I mean
that's how I look at it man it is it is
using your resources intentionally yes
making sure that your focus and your
attention
is exactly where where you need it in
your life to live a meaningful life yeah
and so if we're talking about intention
the opposite of intention is is just
going with the flow and living without
intention yeah and so if you're living
without intention I think most of us are
it's like when you think of maybe
meditation for example the opposite of
meditation is just random thoughts you
know it's the it's excess thinking
that's what we all do we all just sort
where our minds are filled with thoughts
well yeah especially in the the world we
live in right now man I mean how many
impulses do we have a day that I would
love to see a study on that like
impulses that we have today versus a
hundred years ago yeah so 100 years ago
yeah you don't have social media you
don't have email you don't have
technology and that is just vying at our
attention it's it's all of it wants our
attention so yes going with the flow is
is just reacting to every
impulse yes and so simple living means
we have a finite amount of resources
whether that is your money maybe it is
your energy mm-hmm
maybe it is your attention yeah maybe it
is your time or your talent or your
skill set mm-hmm these are all resources
but they're not infinite right and so we
have to be deliberate with the resources
we have
but being unintentional means that we
just Britain we let whatever we let
anything in and we just accept it when I
had the big house in the suburbs it was
a relatively nice house but of course I
had to fill every corner of the house
and if there was space I just let
whatever in I didn't do so with
intention so intentionality or simple
living if I were to define it is the
removing of the excess so we can make
room for what's truly important
you